so do you think a lot of people suffer
from low frustration tolerance and they
absolutely love tee major epidemic yeah
absolutely and and and smartphones and
all the things that they come whether
not help yet in my bed my observation
I'll tell you great thing her friend of
mine studies technology and learning and
he's a professor at the University and
he says to his students every 15 minutes
I'll give you a one minute phone break
hmm I want your phones away I want the
sound turned off and you can text and
answer messages every 15 minutes I'll
give you a minute he says he gets great
focus and concentration from his
students said before I did that all they
were thinking about was this vibrating
in my pocket and what is it and there
were studies that show that kids have
trouble being away from their phones for
certain like the time but if you give
them a long enough time to get something
done but short enough so they know they
can get you if it's important that's a
good idea that kind of cause I was at a
restaurant in in Italy five years ago in
in Siena there's a restaurant that our
friends wanted we were traveling with
them and they wanted to go to and it was
in a cave and a real cave and they had
done this you know something could never
happen to this country happened at the
door you put your cell phone down you
put your name on the back of it and you
put it in a basket it was a cell phone
free restaurant and it was the most
wonderful dining experience I've ever
had there's nothing moods there's
nothing more kids work whatever the
under-30 could be in the room but you
know we're so used to now someone
picking up a cell phone at a table next
to us I don't bring my cell phone mostly
when I go to dinner I don't want to be
bothered what you do when you go to
lunch that's true but so do you that's
to me it's different
so I need you I'm important
you